donc il y a longtemps que j'avais arrêté
l'héroïne la cocaïne plusieurs années
non ah oui vous êtes au courant
comme vous êtes un mec honnête très
honnête un look un peu provincial pas
choice du tout je vais vous faire une
interview mensonge
[Musique]
[Rires]
on la bouche pas pendant le jingle c'est
bien c'est pas bougé c'est parfait
vous roulez toujours en limousine avec
les vitres fumées
à l'école j'aime bien arriver devant
l'école avec
et c'est vrai qu'il y a des années
beaucoup ça c'est vrai c'est une on aime
bien voir les acteurs de cinéma et dans
limousine et vous avez des assistants
qui vous allument vos cigarettes sur les
plateaux beaucoup j'en ai beaucoup je
change souvent parce que
non mais c'est vrai c'est c'est
difficile de supporter de la vie
quotidienne d'un acteur donc
bien
des assistants
on vous a beaucoup vu à Saint-Tropez cet
été avec Arthur avec Carlos avec Collaro
avec Nagui vous êtes passé l'été avec
eux
vous avez déclaré en parlant de ses
vacances là enfin je revis et vous la
retrouvez quoi
c'est à dire que ils ont ils ont des
bateaux énormes et ça ça m'a permis
grâce à eux d'éviter Loana et
moi j'aime beaucoup Loana donc il y a
longtemps que j'avais arrêté l'héroïne
la cocaïne plusieurs années non ah vous
êtes au courant
j'ai quelques fois
et aujourd'hui il fumez combien de
pétards par jour
ça dépend pour l'émission
pas beaucoup pas beaucoup beaucoup
parce que il a du mal pourquoi tu me
regardes
parce que
donc on vous rencontre souvent avec de
jeunes actrices dans les dans les
soirées mondaines
votre épouse accepte ça très facilement
j'ai l'impression non elle est pour
il y a un truc que je comprends pas
c'est cette passion des clubs
échangistes
dans un club échangiste sans vous voir
comme l'a dit Titeuf la dernière fois
c'est pour rencontrer des animateurs
télé parce que j'aime beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu